- [Lecturer] When we think
about European exploration
in the Americas, we tend to start at 1492
with Christopher Columbus showing up
at the island of Hispaniola,
but in this video I
want to take a step back
a few decades and talk
about the conditions
that led to Christopher Columbus's
voyage in the first place.
What was he doing there?
So let's zoom in a little bit
and take a look at what the world
would have looked like to
someone in western Europe
around the year 1450.
So to a European, this would have been
about the extent of the known world.
Now they wouldn't have had anything
like the level of this detail,
but they certainly knew that there were
very good things to be had in India,
and China,
and the Middle East.
Excellent trade goods
like silk and spices,
and they knew there was
quite a lot of world
outside of Europe and Africa,
but they didn't think that
there was much out there.
And they expected there
would be some small islands
on the range of Iceland perhaps,
but they had no conception
that there were two
gigantic continents on the other
side of the Atlantic Ocean.
It's a frequent misconception that people
in this time period thought
that the world was flat.
Learned people of the era
knew that the world was round.
In fact they had known so
since the time of the Greeks.
What they did know was that
the world was pretty large.
In fact they correctly
estimated that the circumference
of the globe is about 25,000 miles.
And so they knew that given
the shipping technology
that they had, it would
be impossible to go west
and arrive at the east, while still having
enough food and water to supply your crew.
Now why would anyone have
dreamt of going west to get east
when they could have simply
gone east to get east?
Well the answer is that
the over land route
was long and it was expensive because
the Middle East and north
Africa and even parts of Spain
were controlled by Muslim empires
like the Ottomans and the Moors.
And so any time trade came from the east,
China and India and
the Middle East itself,
it went through a series of traders
and a series of empires along the way,
picking up taxes
and markups.
Which meant that by the time a good
reached western Europe
it was pricey indeed.
And since Muslim traders were in control
of the Mediterranean here and at the east,
taking a ship through there caused
pretty much the same problem,
so why not go around the coast of Africa?
Well that was certainly something
that Europeans were keen to do.
The only problem is that the wind
goes in the wrong direction
and it's very treacherous
sailing around the tip of Africa
to come up into the Indian Ocean.
So what changed?
How did this over land trade route
become an over sea trade route?
Well for that we have to
look a little bit closer
at the Iberian peninsula.
So this land mass here
is the Iberian peninsula.
And at the time, the Iberian peninsula
was controlled by a number
of different groups.
The southern part was under Muslim control
of the Moors, as they were
called, or Moroccan Muslims
and they called this area Al-Andalus
and we're talking about this area here,
and the Spanish called it Granada.
The western part here was
under the control of Portugal,
as it is today.
So we got Portugal.
The eastern part, this area here,
is the kingdom of Aragon
and then a central part here
was kingdom of Castile.
So as far as Europeans were concerned
this was kind of the end of the world.
This was as far southwest as you could go
on the European continent and heaven knows
what was out here until
in the early 1400s,
Portugal's Prince Henry the Navigator
began investing in navigation.
And one of the important discoveries made
by the Portuguese was a new kind of ship
and this ship was called the caravel.
So what's cool about the caravel is that
caravels are ocean worthy but they're also
very easy to maneuver and
they can sail into the wind.
So, that means that
the problems of sailing
around Africa begin to
get a little bit easier
and so in this early era of the 1400s,
the Portuguese began
expanding their exploration
farther and farther down
the coast of Africa,
and they come across these islands
now that they don't have to hug the coast.
The Canary Islands, and farther west
this is so small you can
barely see it here, Madeira
and the Azores.
And they quickly discover
that these islands
are ideal places to grow cash crops.
Specifically sugar.
They also discover that some of the people
who live on these islands,
in fact the Canary Islands
had a native population
called the Guanche.
They immediately attempted to
enslave these native people
and then quickly discovered
that they would die of disease.
And we'll talk more
about why native people
seemed to be so susceptible
to European diseases a little bit later.
So now they have great
places to grow sugar,
but they don't have a workforce.
Well they're discovering another workforce
along the coast of Africa
as they begin to set up,
this is the Portuguese
we're talking about here,
trading posts on the west coast of Africa
where they're purchasing slaves
from African traders or Arab traders
who had a long history of trading slaves
from the interior of
Africa out to its coast.
So in the early 1400s,
Portugal is doing very well for itself.
Seems that they're leading
this colonial game.
They've pretty much invented
the plantation system,
and they're getting
quite wealthy off of it.
So the eyes of Europe turn to Portugal
and they think all right how
can we replicate their success?
Meanwhile, back on the Iberian peninsula
there's a political and religious shakeup,
so the kingdoms of Castile
and Aragon are united
when Ferdinand of Aragon
and Isabella of Castile
and I recognize that my Spanish
pronunciation is terrible,
they get married in 1469
and unite their two kingdoms
into what becomes the kingdom of Spain.
So what had been Castile
and Aragon becomes Spain.
And then united, these
two Catholic monarchs
turn their attentions to
what's called the reconquista.
So reconquering the territories
that had been controlled
by Muslims for Christians.
Some call this kind of an
extension of Crusader thinking,
and Ferdinand and Isabella
complete the reconquista,
expelling the Moors from the territory
that is today Spain in 1492.
So now we've reached 1492 and we've got
a will, that is a desire for luxury goods.
We also have a little bit of
good old fashioned nationalism here.
Spain's closest neighbor is
Portugal, who are currently
very powerful and wealthy, so they've got
perhaps some rivalry in their hearts,
and we've got a way which is the caravel
that is making more and
more ocean sailing possible.
And into this exciting moment
steps Christopher Columbus,
and we'll talk more about
him in the next video.